I wonder what he did to trigger I wonder
what he done that causes a reaction I
wonder what he must have said
this is something that a lot of men are
going through I know
like a reaction
s
the only thing I would just add is that
I hope that the board here for this
organization will scream panelists that
come through here because I was married
to one of the panelists who actually
accused me of Zina
um
I want you to stop and contemplate for a
moment what would you do if lies and
slander and stories from the figment of
one's evil imagination about you or your
loved ones were being spread within your
community
people back in the day when they would
have to travel certain distances for
months or even years what is one thing
that they would carry with them the
Quran why because they did not have it
on their mobile devices or their gadgets
brothers and sisters imagine you have a
app the qurani app which not only shows
you how much rewards you get but reminds
you to read the Quran gives you
reminders app now and let it testify for
you on your makayama that you read it
wherever you was there was a video that
was sent to me and this video was of a
brother
and I watched this whole video watched
it entirely and I'm going to tell you
guys why I was Intel in Italian listen
to it very carefully this is a
phenomenon that's happening and a lot of
people you know I say this before over
and over again from the bitty truth show
to the marriage documentary
to a project that I'm working on which
is an app people think genuinely and
Allah is my witness if I am doing these
projects for the money if I am now doing
it just for the views or the fame now do
I struggle with these things of course I
do that's my intentions one day for me
one day for that against me of course I
do so I'm not entirely saying that I'm
free from the fame and the views and
this that I come no I have intentional
problems but that's besides the point I
start these projects because I see a
problem and to me when I see a problem I
like to deal with the problem that's
personally myself and as men without
biology we're problem solvers really
with logical thinkers so to me when I
saw this problem I thought to myself
subhanallah that I should do it there
should be some sort of a solution that's
why I started the bitter truth show one
of the reasons I start the bit true show
because there's a direct attack on the
family unit but I saw a lot of
aggression a lot of aggression not only
aggression oppression against men the
tide has changed yes men can be the
culprits of domestic violence so could
studies show that women are as violent
as men it's the only difference between
the man and the woman is what that a man
uses more lethal Force because if I was
to you know hit my wife yeah for that
matter it will cause more pain to her
than she it's me unless there's
exceptions to the rule that she's an MMA
fighter yeah okay so in that aspect
that's what Allah when it comes to the
Quran Allah legislates if you fear
aggression or um your wife Crossing
limits that what the protocols you do
I'm trying to say that you speak to her
and if not then you depart from the bed
and if not then you can use some kind of
a foster restrainer but interestingly in
a different verse in the Quran Allah
doesn't give the same prescription to
the woman rather tells the woman to get
the family family members involved why
because it will be on it wouldn't make
sense to ask the woman to use some kind
of a force to restrain the man because
she does not have those capabilities to
do so now with this very instance
subhanallah I'm watching this video and
I'm thinking to myself how many Muslim
feminist women feminists are not
feminists are watching this and I bet
you any money you can and I'll tell you
the link this is of a brother who who
was married to a female
um speaker yes a female speaker who's
given dawa who if you saw hijab if you
saw her face you were not in a million
billion years think this woman do all
the villain oppression to the level of
trying to get the get him killed yes
none of us would think that and you know
what there'll be so many Muslim women
feminist liberal values watching that
video and I bet you any money the
question that they would say is the
following I wonder
I wonder what he did to trigger I wonder
what he done that causes of react I
wonder what he must have said I wanted
you see as men just because we look
physically strong doesn't mean we are
stronger mentally
there is a lot of women because that's
why you look at statistics a lot of men
are the ones that take their lives you
will need to ask and beg the question
why do we is there awareness race to
this no who cares who cares and even if
you look at Islam there is strict strict
guidelines to how to deal with how when
I'm in deal I'm not talking about that
sense here how
in in when you're dealing with your wife
your sister whoever that may it may be
Allah protocols in place and Allah has
given the right like Allah above for a
man because of the responsibilities that
he has and the prophet Muhammed peaceful
from him said if I was to ask anybody to
prostrate to anybody it would be their
wife to the husband why why are these
protocols in place because Allah knows
how he created a woman he knows how he
created a woman and he knows that for
example how he's created him then and
how they should be dealt with in
different situations when they're
emotional when they're upset when
they're going from the highs from their
lows even when they're causing them
Allah has allowed the man to be a leader
so when you watch this video you see the
levels this brother went through and I'm
going to say something on this as well
because I I personally I'm not told I'm
there's Parts where I'm blaming the
prophet but there is only for one thing
and this can apply to all us men we have
forgotten how to be men we have
forgotten so much so that we are
cowardly we are cowards we do not have
the gods the audacity to say something
we are afraid to tell our woman folk our
wives you are not coming up the house
without that lipstick you are not
wearing that dress I do not want you to
speak to that person
yes or you have to be at home at this
time you are not going out at this time
and when I'm talking about these things
I'm not talking about being strict I
don't talk to my wife like that you know
unless she requires me to alhamdulillah
I don't need to I don't need to come and
tell my best Mercy we're not talking
about that that's put that to the side
of course that is a given in a marriage
every man should be the protector
provider have love mercy and take care
of their kids yes if you are a man who
work or a self-employed whatever and
you're in the house well lied at him I
enjoy looking after my kids I love
changing my kids I love change their
nappies unless they're beaut yeah that's
not for me I'm not sorry I can't do that
yeah unless you say necessity okay and
there's my there's my daughter laughing
at me at the back here so me I love
spending time with my kids but the point
is what and we should as men it doesn't
mean that we should be like you know
we'll cause role in oppression Etc
that's not being a man the point is what
look at the level of loan this man went
through and let me tell you guys
something which is personal and it's in
the marriage documentary in two thousand
15. myself there is this personal
personal story that I'm going to share
with you guys because when I heard the
story
I could relate to it Yes mine was a bit
more crazier on a different side and why
am I mentioning this to you I don't need
to mention this to you guys the reason I
mention it to you is because the men are
going through this I hear multiple
stories of brothers who cannot see their
kids
who their wealth and property has been
taken off them they have been accused of
rape I know of a brother who when he
called me he was in a Cell prison cell
why he's like bro I am being accused of
rap and is taking off but Allah because
bro I've never done that women are
causing Great Lengths or volume and
oppression and how many sisters female
speakers are talking about this how many
how many I sent this video to one
specific sister on purpose yes she knows
who she is
the reply that I got was she was a
couple of minutes of it and it was that
she felt it was messy
and I have to be like well hold on a
second when it comes to the brothers you
know and you know people love to jump on
like I mean just imagine for a split
second that my wife
or if I imagine I had an ex-wife an
ex-wife came out and said Ali and she
was crying and said Ali hit me or did
this but without verification without
answering questions without even knowing
that not how what who when is it even
true there would be a let me tell you
something I would have been hang upside
down on the tree upside down on the tree
but when it's a man that's going through
this nobody's come to the help so much
so that religious leaders
yes there were some names from that I
want to get into details because I need
to add the contact details and I would
like to understand and clarification
more but even then we can see the
feminist narrative the liberal narrative
the men imams are afraid sheikhs mufti's
Duart are us afraid
I'm not afraid
I am not afraid to talk against Rome
against anybody for that matter that is
the reason why I'm quite vocal on
certain points there are brothers
brothers who have been threatened with
all sorts why because they choose to
islamically get married again
islamically you're not going to see your
kids in-laws the in-laws flipping on
them all these other elements why
because of something Halal has been done
go to that level yes religious illness
religious in-laws praying five times a
day in the Masjid religious in-laws the
moment the guy wants to get married
again halad
Allah there's no Islam Islam is gone at
the window so I can see that in and it
really triggers me because how many
people are talking about the zoom that
is being done and the system is also on
the woman's side men who cannot see
their kids there was another brother
subhanallah there was a research that I
went to the other one's getting into
details I was there this brother like
you know you went through a divorce and
he hasn't seen his kids in about three
weeks time and I can see the sorrow in
his heart and I thought to myself
just imagine for a second I take my kids
away from my wife
for not apparent reason
yeah foreign
there'll be so much everybody will be
talking about it why are people afraid
when somebody has been wronged oh the
community to hell with the community if
a brother is being wrong we need to be
more vocal so I'm going out to all the
sister speakers out there they should be
talking about this matter directly or
indirectly this is a growing problem
where women are causing great levels of
Zone and oppression unjustly on innocent
men and one thing that I'll say I'll say
to all the sisters
I'm saying that they don't talk about
I'm just calling out to our sisters
you know
um
and the list goes on and even Brothers
make a big deal out of this talk about
this talk about this and I'm going to
end on this note
I want everybody to talk about this
hijab all the brothers that watches up
contact them in private as well talk and
raise awareness of this and want against
this woman sister Dunya yes sister Dunya
yeah or pressing people in the Dunya
your name is Sister Dunya you are going
to question the question about it
and one thing that I'm going to say to
the brother my dear brother who's
watching this
I am sorry that you had to go through
this even though you are a grown man
still we don't shed tears as men we
don't shed tears we cry internal Inside
Yes because if we do believe we called
you know oh you know grow up Etc nobody
will believe us yeah we accuse you so
many and we carry the salt the the
burden of so many things on our
shoulders including our family our
responsibility yeah men are there to put
their lives at the risk for the family I
know many men who will die for their
family members but my brother I want to
give you an Asia yes
I come from a jahilia there's certain
things that I've been exposed to I have
become I've been a Muslim for the past
10 years understand the biology and the
mentality and the psychology of a woman
the fact that you were saying I did this
for her and that for her she wanted this
and I gave her this and this and she
wanted that and I did this
my brother the moment he was mentioning
this I'm not having to go at you I'm not
having to go at you yeah you was the
better person in this and Allah exposed
her yes and if she wants to come and
talk about her side which I think
everything is clear from his side no
problem I will even link that as well
yeah even though the matters are cleared
the fact that she couldn't go to the
police and Reporting Stuff shows me what
she is about yes
and I know personal experience as well
so to me is this buffer if you go and
give a woman everything that she wants I
don't blame nobody my brother in this
very instant story yes she's wrong and
she wronged you but you
you need to understand a woman is
programmed in a certain way she needs a
leader and by the way I'm not saying
you're not a leader please please
understand me she needs a man a leader
when he says no it's a no
because you have chosen that leader for
your household and once again I'm not
talking about doing oppression of them
on your wives the prophet Muhammad peace
give us a clear Criterion yeah class yes
we have to know how we treat our wives
but he's also given us strict guidelines
how to deal with do our wives when they
cross the mark yes so to us Mercy should
be there but also there needs to be
certain things when you cut you cut yeah
and my principle in life is what whoever
it may be my loved ones are a person
that I care for I will give them my 100
percent
the moment I notice or the moment I feel
and the moment I sense that my kindness
is being taken for weakness and my
generosity and my care has been taken
for granted and I am being now you know
then what I do is I cut that you know
that top I cut that water top nicely and
they use that flowing water and they
start realizing and they start poking
and seeing little driplets and they're
like you know it was good when it was
good you need to understand the
psychology of a woman and the prophet
Muhammad said what the woman who prays
our basic Salah does the basics and is
protects her Chastity her modesty when
her husband is away and it's good to her
husband her husband says I am pleased
with with my wife Allah will see to that
woman enter gender through any door why
is there not a Hadith pretending to the
this uh opposite way to a woman this
doesn't mean that you don't treat women
well no no no but it can show you that
the psychology which is what sadly that
we know that the prophet Muhammad peace
be upon him he went to the Hellfire and
he saw a majority of the inhabitants of
women and why their companions asked did
they commit Comfort towards Allah he
said rather no they are ungrateful to
their husbands that if their husband
does so many good things one bad thing I
have seen nothing good from good from
them and the prophet Muhammad gave a
solution to the woman that were asking
about this which was what he said to
them give in because the prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him said save
yourself from the fire even if you give
half a date in charity so my dear
brothers and sisters please please and
Imam
this woman who looks so meskin in this
hijab that you were never in a
millionaire think that was the biggest
shayateen in the marriage outside the
marriage and probably till this day and
nobody in that
um Community raise awareness to this he
was even in a a talk went on a mic and
asking the question they disregarded him
imagine a sister coming to an event and
crying and saying my husband beat me
there'll be World War seven World War
seven the nuclear bombs found everywhere
but when it's a man who cares because
but internally we suffer and you look at
statistics men are more prone to commit
suicide so my dear brothers and sisters
please raise awareness to this and those
female female speakers you guys as well
should be talking out against us enough
is enough that's all I have to say till
next time may Allah bless you guys
brother sisters